Jason Garrett's coaching contract has
expired in Dallas and in theory anybody
else who wants to hire him could I don't
think that's gonna happen Jerry Jones
who said over the years if Jason Garrett
was ever available they'd be lining up
to hire him but that's not the case and
Jerry Jones made it Jason after the game
one last night out there on the field
apparently does that all the time after
the games hanging out with family really
soaking it all in and and it would be a
stunner at this point if he's back it
would go against every message every
clue every indication we've gotten from
the Cowboys that they expect this team
to do great things they have put
together the most talent eeeem they've
had since they won Super Bowls right and
they couldn't even get to the playoffs
this year it was clear going in that
Jerry Jones was using the incentive of
an expiring contract as a carrot for
Jason Garrett it didn't work and now and
Jerry Jones met with the media last
night for a half hour yeah he wouldn't
talk about Garrett's status but it
became clear change is coming the only
change it isn't coming there won't be a
new general manager for the Cowboys
because Jerry Jones isn't firing himself
other than that everything's gonna
happen yeah well you take the Dallas
Cowboys job you don't have to deal with
the Jones family okay it's not the worst
I mean yeah they're a pain in the butt
but they want to win they got a pretty
good eye for talent and we've seen that
you know I don't this is the worst part
of the this job for me right here is
these little segments because Jason
Garrett is one of the finest human
beings in the NFL he really is you
couldn't find a nicer and more normal
guy did he do some good things in Dallas
definitely did but yeah the the time has
come it's just it ran its course and you
said it the team was talented I mean you
just watch the game yesterday Troy
Aikman's he's saying it on the telecast
yeah this Cowboys teams as talented as
any team in football yeah they are
there's no doubt about it but there is
some element missing and what that is
exactly I don't know it doesn't match up
though when you have a top 10 defense
and a top two or three offense and
you're only eight and eight that means
something in the management of the game
or situational football or you lost the
team or pre snaps looks whatever it may
be right that was the problem before
this year yeah right there was some
issues hey last week against the Heat
fill it up
back to it right I complained to you I
think off air here we were in game again
there was no motions no shifts I don't
know what happened so I just think the
the time has come don't feel guilty
about this aspect of the job though
because these guys know going in yeah I
know right it's the grows on Gruden
fired Football Coaches Association you
either have been fired or you're gonna
be fired very rarely does a guy walk
away on his own terms that's how it
works
because the NFL is the ultimate zero-sum
game for every team that wins there's a
team that loses they're not all going to
be eight and eight so these great teams
like the Ravens and the 49ers that they
are fattening up their records at the
expense of the bad team yeah sure and so
the bad teams are gonna change coaches
that's just the way it is especially
with the salary cap you can't fire your
team you can't say we're getting rid of
all 53 guys and starting over again
you've got to keep a certain number of
your players the only thing you can do
to make a major change from one year to
the next is change coaches and they know
that they get compensated for it I'm not
saying we should be hard-hearted about
it but I also think we shouldn't we
shouldn't ya know I know upset about it
yeah it goes with the territory and they
all know you're right I mean hey listen
I I knew you're right I I hear you
actually feel good about you giving me
that's that speech I knew right Luis
running into me at full-speed was not
good for my health and then maybe I
could lose an organ one day oh I lost
one so yeah I mean that's just what
happens but it'd be interesting to see
at least you didn't lose a vital one no
at least not a vital one you're right
now I only get every sickness in the
world and everything I'm just saying
like you know there are other organs
that it would have been kind of hard to
yeah I lost my heart but what happens
with Jason Garrett I think that's a real
interesting conversation I don't think
he's going to be in the coaching
carousel this younger I don't get
happening no and who would hire him to
be an offensive coordinator ya know yeah
he's he's I mean eventually I could see
that happening and then he's gonna have
to go kind of reor castrates what he
does as an offensive play caller and
kind of make his mark again I think to
be if he wants to be a head coach one
more time and he and he doesn't get the
luxury of a buyout because there's no
contract that thought-out right we were
talking about this yesterday the
possibility of him going to TV because
he brings that cowboys angle yeah
problem is if he wants to get back into
coaching he isn't gonna say anything
right right because you can't go on TV
and start spilling stories about the cow
boys and the Joneses and then right and
then oh you're gonna spill stories about
me after you're no longer my head coach
you know the the former coaches who want
back in former GM's who want back in are
for the most part useless when it comes
to TV now they'll tell you what they're
gonna say and then when it's time to say
it
they ain't gonna say it because they
know that it potentially cuts off their
ability to get back in yeah no you're
right that's a very delicate situation
and you're it's not gonna be the best
for me I think it's one of those
situations take the year off if you're
Jason Garrett
maybe somebody hires use an offensive
coordinator and you just go back that
way he had a good run with the Dallas
Cowboys was a perfect know his best
chance to get back in would be this Gary
Kubiak assistant head coach ur offensive
advisory type right you're not giving
him the keys to an office oh definitely
that ship has sailed
and I felt right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports